I'm David Brockway I'm the manager of
the great men project we deliver
workshops on gender equality to teenage
boys in schools across London and the
South East our topics include sexual
harassment homophobia pornography and
consent but especially we talk about
masculinity feminism and what it really
means to be a man
[Applause]
[Music]
adult men don't really talk about these
issues very much we want to get the
conversation normalized starting at an
early age we use participate your
activities such as word association
games these allow the boys to explore
the stereotypes that might be in their
heads we'll ask them to talk about the
first words that come into their head
when they think of a certain topic for
instance when I asked to think about men
they may come up with brave strong or
daring for women they make them up with
gentle kind and caring so then we ask
how and why what causes these
stereotypes where do the boys get ideas
like it's week four meant to cry or men
are strong women a week most of the boys
have never had conversations like this
before all most powerful moments are
when we have light bulb moments when
boys have the opportunity through
talking to each other to realize that
some of these ideas that they think they
know are actually a result of
conditioning and the world around them
toxic masculinity is talked about a lot
these days we would define it as a set
of negative behaviors that men think
they have to follow in order to be
proper men on top of the litany of
negative consequences that these
behaviors have for women and girls there
are also many negative consequences for
men and boys at the top of this list
would be mental health and suicide
suicide rates in this country are
currently much higher for men than they
are for women in our workshops we find
that boys have a lot of difficulty
expressing their emotions accepting
emotional vulnerability and admitting to
any form of weakness our workshops
encourage boys to critique phrases such
as man up and take it like a man which
are really saying boys don't cry and
boys don't ask for help when they're
feeling down the phrase man up is
particularly important for us it's two
words that put together mean absolutely
nothing but any man can tell you that
when told to do so they know exactly
what was expected of them at that time
for years the responsibility of dealing
with these problems has been on women
grappling with sexism sexual harassment
and harassment at work we feel that
solving these issues is equally the
responsibility of men that's why it's so
important to get these conversations
started early to bring boys into this
discussion so that they can have a
chance to not take forward those
negative ideas and stereotype
one of our most difficult topics is
pornography approach is not to shame
anyone but to ask questions such as is
this a good place to learn about sex
chemistry degrading and where's the
consent in this we aim to educate the
boys about the porn industry to tell
them that can often be unsafe and
coercive for women that the things on
display of rarely representative of a
mutually pleasurable sexual experience
sometimes the boys you work with go back
to a home environment that is contrary
to all of the things we've discussed
what they are taught in London and media
is the total opposite of discussions
they had robust healthy relationships
are about respecting caring and
communicating our aim is to plant a seed
that will allow the boys you work with
to start questioning these things and
create their own version of being a man
you